but also at the same time who's come to
their savior is china right and you kind
of brought up china yourself earlier
this morning secretary anthony blinken
sends a tweet out right i don't know if
you heard this or not or if you read
this i'm sure you have
beijing should let the voices of all
hong kongers be heard the prc's
disqualification of district councillors
only weakens hong kong's long-term
political and social stability we stand
with the people of hong kong and
continue to support their human rights
and fundamental freedoms this is
secretary anthony blinken sends this at
five to uh this is uh uh
goes out uh
uh uh uh
i don't know what time they're 5 26 p.m
apparently this is yesterday when he
sends his tweet what happens immediately
he takes it down he deletes the tweet
right and takes a tweet down this may
been a couple days ago and then that
generated a couple different uh theories
some would call it a conspiracy theory
some call it a theory why is he taking
it down
is he taking it down because who's the
one country that hates that message it's
only one and we know who that is it's
china if jack ma said one thing about
hong kong jack ma lost all his money and
if anybody voices too much defending
hong kong it doesn't sit too
well with them what role is china
playing today that scares our secretary
anthony blinken
from the most powerful country in the
world to delete a tweet just because
china's upset where is the connection
there with china taliban and u.s let me
tell you one thing patrick
united states had massive leverage in
this particular region but with their
steps the exit strategy they have
completely lost any kind of that
leverage and china on the other hand has
increased that leverage to a great
extent and let's also remember patrick
that there are many american citizens
who are still
on afghan soil
now the priority of the biden
administration as they say in their own
words is to actually rescue those
citizens and we know how closely
embedded china is right now pakistan is
right now with
of course uh you know the taliban and
perhaps anthony blinken now this is i'm
just guessing it i do not know what the
reality is but perhaps
he thought that china
or got some kind of an intelligence that
china will not like it
china may take some aggressive steps and
reciprocate in some way not in china not
in us but in afghanistan
that's my fear right now because i
realize this because it's not just
americans there are many other
you know international citizens who are
there in afghan soil and many countries
are facing a tough time with the taliban
and taliban on the other hand is using
these citizens who receive money who
receive humanitarian aid to receive
whatever is possible
at the stake so
at one
of time this is an embarrassing moment
for the biden administration and anthony
blinken uh after the kind of a rhetoric
spree that trump went into against china
is the biden administration again going
to have a hot and cold approach towards
china uh ahead of you know um it's the
unga you know what uh biden said at unga
he said he does not want any kind of a
cold war strategy he does not want
another renewed approach of a cold war
happening he said we will go on a
diplomatic street
all across the world now
perhaps
he does believe that he does not want
another war perhaps he does realize that
he doesn't want another kind of iraq or
afghanistan but is this how your
approach is really going to be
by abandoning people completely by
actually emboldening terror groups to
attack your closest allies
and to leave afghan people high and dry
without any kind of a support and now
perhaps becoming an ally of the taliban
where you not just send a humanitarian
aid
but leave
massive amounts of ammunition for them
to use against you and your allies so i
think china is going to increasingly
play a very significant and important
role in afghanistan they're going to
invest massively they already have some
projects underway in afghanistan
including railway projects because there
has been uh the road connectivity pro
project which is very close and dear to
fiji pink and they want to connect not
just
with pakistan with afghanistan but to
entire central asia now will that bring
any kind of economic dividends for
xi ji ping or china that is up for
debate right now but certainly
strategically it is going to be a
win-win situation for china at least in
the immediate future so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you